we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a caller making a
point about those who love to say I've
done my research take a listen to this
hi David I think we really need to push
back against people who say they do
their own research or just this idea
that research is something you can do
research is a term used to describe what
phds do it's used to describe Grant
funded activities costing millions of
dollars with tens of thousands of people
involved this idea that people are doing
research is absurd okay what they're
actually doing is consuming information
are they critical of that information
are they consuming the right kinds of
information these are the things we need
to be discussing but when it comes to
discussions about should you do your own
research whatever it's absurd because
they're using this term research
inappropriately okay I get the idea so
what we're talking about here this is
interesting they're talking about
colloquial versus formal language and
I'll give you another example many
people will often say in casual
conversation or either like a political
analyst will say I have a theory or
people will write to me say David I have
a theory the term Theory
in science means it's a scientific
theory meaning well substantiated
explanation of some aspect of the world
we have vast evidence we have
observations we have experimentation
logical reasoning it's a comprehensive
framework that the science Community has
said this is the best explanation we
have for some phenomena and it is
evidence-based Etc it's been tested it's
often been peer reviewed Etc it's been
scrutinized in casual conversation when
we say I have a theory we know that what
you mean is you have a hypothesis and
yeah sure to some degree would it be
more accurate for people to say I have a
hypothesis about what's going to happen
in 2024 sure it's more accurate but
sometimes we use the same words
differently when it's colloquial versus
when it's formal when we talk about
research it's true when someone says
when some anti-vaxx person says I did my
research or when I say it or whatever
the case may be we're talking about
someone who is gathering information
it's it's an it's an information
gathering process with which you then
are ideally coming to some conclusion
about phenomena in everyday life do
vaccines cause autism well I've
researched it okay what you mean is you
gathered information that others have
done other research other people have
done true
actual research would be we are
comprehensively and systematically
um uh using established methodologies to
generate new knowledge and then they are
being peer reviewed and okay I get it
research is a rigorous methodology that
most of us are not doing when we say
we're doing our research however I would
focus more on the people who say I've
done my research
often what they mean is they read a
foxnews.com article we would do better I
believe instead of saying random people
don't do research you're not working in
an academic research setting or a
medical research setting instead of
focusing on that I would focus on giving
people a better structure
for getting information about topics
they're trying to learn about so they
don't end up on conspiracy websites I
think we would get more from that but
obviously the voicemail is accurate in
that the term research means something
that is very different than you know
sitting at home and looking at a daily
wire article I agree with that 100 we
have a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about George Santos agreeing
to settle a lawsuit in Brazil this is
separate from the criminal charges we
will talk about the North Carolina
governor vetoing a 12-week abortion ban
and we will talk about split juries and
the impact and Legacy that this has left
in prisons all over the country all of
those stories and more are on today's
bonus show which you can sign up for and
get instant access to at joinpakman.com
see everybody tomorrow